[Musique]
et c'est lors du journal de l'afrique
soyez les bienvenus à la une ce soir
roch marc christian kaboré de retour à
son domicile à ouagadougou une
libération surveillée des militaires
entoure la résidence de l'ex-président
les précisions de notre correspondant
dans la capitale burkinabè au début de
ce journal
nous reviendrons sur ce rapport de l'eau
angie minority rights group elle pointe
du doigt les exactions commises contre
la minorité batwa en république
démocratique du congo violente et chassé
du parc national de kahuzi biega par les
gardes du parc et des soldats de l'armée
congolaise nous serons en ligne avec
julie barrière de l'omg minority rights
group
et puis nous irons au rwanda lente huit
ans après le génocide des tutsis les
associations se sont donné pour but de
préserver la mémoire des rescapés
interview filmée une digitalisation des
documents en fond documentaire est en
création le reportage à la fin de ce
journal
sa libération était exigée par la cedeao
c'est désormais chose faite ou presque
roch marc christian kaboré a bien
regagné son domicile de ouagadougou mais
des militaires surveillent le périmètre
un transfert effectué mercredi en toute
discrétion ce jeudi les membres du mpp
ont réclamé la libération totale de l'ex
président les précisions de kalidou sy à
ouagadougou
c'est dans un communiqué diffusé
mercredi soir que le gouvernement
burkinabè a informé que suite à des
concertations entamées il ya trois
semaines avec l'ancien président du faso
ce dernier a pu regagner son domicile
familial mais selon nos informations
bien que l'ex président roch kaboré est
gagné et regagner son domicile familial
il ne s'agit pas de remise en liberté il
se trouve toujours en situation de
résidence surveillée seule sa famille
peut lui rendre visite d'ailleurs al
annonce son retour à son domicile
familial de la patte d'oie des partisans
ont tenté la lui rendre visite mais ont
été refoulés par le dispositif
sécuritaire rappelons que depuis le coup
d'état du désormais président paul henri
sandaogo damiba son encontre c'était le
24 janvier dernier
rck à bord était en résidence surveillée
dans une villa ministérielle du quartier
de ouaga 2000 les membres de son parti
un pépé alassane bâ la 50e en tête l'ex
président de l'assemblée nationale et
par ailleurs président du mouvement du
peuple pour le progrès avait été
interpellé le 27 mars d'année après
avoir demandé sa libération rappelons
également qu'à la suite de rencontres
avec le président dany bar la cedeao
avait sommé les autorités burkinabè de
libérer l'ancien président de façon
inconditionnelle et sans délai vous
l'aurez compris alors que l'ex président
henri kaboré a pu regagner son domicile
il n'a toujours pas été remis en liberté
la côte d'ivoire entendra-t-elle l'appel
de la famille de thomas sankara les
avocats de la famille de l'ex président
burkinabè assassiné lors d'un putsch en
1987 ont réclamé l'extradition de blaise
compaore ce dernier a été condamné à
perpétuité dans cette affaire mais il
vit en exil en côte d'ivoire depuis 2000
14 où il a obtenu la nationalité on
écoute prosper farama l'avocat de la
partie civile je parle d'une parodie de
justice qu'on veut alors l'état doivent
être tous les moyens en eux à respecter
les droits des personnes qu'on aime nous
insistons histoire pour que cette
décision soit exécuté s'il doit
maintenant après avoir droit à une grâce
à une amnistie car ce soit dans les
rêves de la
cto et moi j'espère que la patinoire
comprendra que ce jour-là une session du
destin des pays membres quatre ans d'un
continent en malice le procureur du
tribunal militaire de mopti a annoncé
l'ouverture d'une enquête sur les
événements de morat et la mission de
l'onu aussi aimerait enquêter sur les
opérations menées dans cette localité du
centre du pays entre le 23 et le 31 mars
selon l'armée malienne plus de 200
jihadistes ont été neutralisés une
version contredite par les ong human
rights watch selon qui trois cents
civils auraient été exécutés par des
soldats maliens associés à des
combattants étrangers de la société
russe wagner l'émissaire onusien el
ghassim one a donc réclamé jeudi 6 au
gouvernement malien malien d'autoriser
un accès impératif sur les lieux on
l'écouté
si l'annoncé mercredi par le procureur
du tribunal militaire de mopti
l'ouverture d'une enquête y compris le
déploiement sur le terrain du personnel
requis est une initiative bienvenue il
est impératif que les autorités
maliennes apporte la coopération
nécessaire pour que la minus mas est
accès au site des violations présumées
conformément à son mandat
les forces armées maliennes dit avoir
neutralisé des dizaines d'éléments
terroristes présents dans la zone en
parallèle la minustah a également reçu
des rapports faisant état de graves
violations des droits humains commises
contre un grand nombre de civils au
cours de cette opération
l'autorisation pour le déploiement d'une
mission intégré n'a jusqu'à présent pas
été délivré
en guinée à peine investi est déjà
inculpé par la justice ibrahima kassory
fofana président provisoire du rpg arc
en ciel a été arrêté avec lui trois
autres anciens ministres du régime déchu
d'alpha condé les quatre hommes ont été
auditionnées dans le cadre d'une enquête
préliminaire de corruption et de
blanchiment de capitaux plus de détails
avec malik et diakité notre
correspondant à conakry
ibrahima kassory fofana ancien premier
ministre récemment investi comme
président provisoire du rpg arc en ciel
le parti du président dessus alpha condé
les anciens ministres mohamed diané
zakaria coulibaly et enfin oyé
guilavogui tous sont poursuivis pour des
faits présumés d'enrichissement illicite
et de détournement des deniers publics
on ignore pour l'heure le fait précis
qui leur sont reprochés
d'abord auditionné pendant trois jours à
la direction centrale des investigations
judiciaires ils ont été conduits mes
crédits de voir l'accord de reprise sont
des infractions économiques et
financières
aussitôt arrivés ils ont été inculpés et
placés sous mandat de dépôt à la prison
centrale de conakry leur avocat cris à
un acharnement politique nous sommes
dans une cabale judiciaire
c'est une justice expéditive que nous
venons d'assister nous pensons que
c'est purement politique tout ça c'est
purement politique c'est une façon de
neutraliser les adversaires politiques
c'est une impasse en d'anéantir les
personnes qui peuvent être gênantes
c'est une façon de se servir de la
justice pour intimider les personnalités
qui ont géré ce pays le procureur
spécial de l'accueil f la cour de
répression des infractions économiques
et financières n'a donné aucune réponse
à notre demande d'interview
selon leur avocat les quatre hommes
comparaîtront lundi prochain devant le
tribunal
c'est un rapport qui jettent une lumière
crue sur le traitement de la minorité
batwa en république démocratique du
congo et plus précisément dans le parc
national de kahuzi biega lo ng mines
minority rights group a enquêté sur
trois années de campagne d'expulsions de
ce peuple de leurs terres ancestrales
selon ce rapport des gardes du parc et
des soldats de l'armée congolaise ont
tué au moins 20 bat toi tu es violet en
groupe au moins quinze femmes et
déplacés par la force des centaines
d'autres après que leurs villages ont
été réduits en cendres nous sommes en
ligne avec julie barrière bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes coordinatrice des
programmes juridique auprès de minority
rights group international qui sont les
bacs toi et pourquoi font-ils l'objet de
violences de la part des gardes du parc
et des soldats de l'armée congolaise
alors les batwa font partie d'une
minorité ethnique et sont membres d'une
communauté autochtone qui vit dans la
forêt leurs terres ancestrales donc qui
est situé à issy dans l'est de la
république démocratique du congo donc
cette forêt est devenue un parc en 1970
le pm cab est donc le volailler
mentionné le parc national cosy dégâts
et fait partie du pâtis patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco depuis 1981 donc
quand ce parc a été créé il est devenu
interdit dans le droit national
congolais pour ces peuples de vivre ou
même d'accéder à leurs terres
donc ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
comme il s'agit d'un peuple autochtone
leur identité elle subsistance dépend
totalement de cet accès à ses terres
donc quand il y retourne pour des
raisons spirituelles culturelles ou pour
récolter des plantes médicinales pour se
nourrir ils font face à des violences de
la part des gardes des violences à armer
donc en 2018 vivant dans l'extrême
pauvreté étant exclues de cette forêt
et sans avoir bénéficié de réparation
judiciaire après les premières
expulsions un groupe de bateaux a décidé
de se ré de réinstaller de se
réinstaller sur leurs terres et c'est là
que une vague de violences a est survenu
entre 2019 et 2021 et ces violences ont
été menées comme vous l'avez dit par les
parts du k2 du ou par les gardes du parc
et les militaires congolais donc
minority rights group international a
commissionné un rapport d'un journaliste
d'investigation robert flower fait qui a
travaillé pendant quatorze mans et à
documenter de manière très minutieuse
les violations graves des droits humains
en allant dans les villages en parlant
genres allant aussi sur aller les tombes
fraîchement creusées
suite aux violences donc ces violences
on était quand même planifié organisé et
commises par les gardes du penjab et
contre les batwa pendant la période que
j'ai mentionnés alors j'ai tomber les
barrières on comprend en lisant aussi
votre rapport que des intérêts
financiers sont aussi en jeu de quel
montant on parle exactement donc il est
impossible à ce jour de vous donner un
montant précis
cependant ce que l'on sait c'est qu'il y
a deux organisations qui soutiennent le
parc 1 rdc donc c'est la kfw donc la
banque allemande de développement donc
le gouvernement allemand et ios aide le
gouvernement américain donc on ne peut
pas déduire quel montant est alloué
précisément au parc parce que c'est des
politiques qui travaillent sur la
conservation de plusieurs parcs au congo
mais combinés on est autour de 75 lyon
d'euros alloués à la conservation dans
une partie assez conséquente sûrs et
donné à le hisser cn donc directement
l'institut congolais pour la
conservation de la nature alors on sait
que les gouvernements allemands et
américains ont été mis au courant de ces
violences à l'égard de la minorité bats
toi pourtant ils n'ont pas retiré leur
financement
en effet ce qui est
c'est très difficile de dissocier c'est
à dire qu'en fait ces gouvernements et
organisations font partie intégrante
d'un système de conservation donc dans
l'unité l'unique objectif final la
conservation militarisée du parc peu
importe les conséquences
évidemment cela n'est pas exprimé de
manière si claire si direct les dommages
collatéraux semble être acceptée même
qu'il s'agisse de violations des droits
de l'homme merci beaucoup julie
barrières pour votre éclairage sur
justement ces exactions contre la
minorité batwa en république
démocratique du congo merci beaucoup
le rwanda commémore aujourd'hui le 28e
anniversaire du génocide des tutsi un
enjeu de mémoire pour plusieurs
associations qui se sont lancés dans la
collecte des témoignages des rescapés et
leurs digitalisation c'est le cas de
l'organisation ibuka de l'omg aiguise
trust qui ont pour objectif la
construction d'un fonds documentaire en
ligne voyez ce reportage de simon
wohlfarth
beata mot car le beau gars s'apprête à
livrer son témoignage
cette septuagénaire a survécu au
génocide
paul rault kesha et son équipe de
caméraman sont venus lui rendre visite
los angels enregistre son récit tragique
pour alimenter des bibliothèques
numériques
[Musique]
non c'est l'effet non vous avais alors
il faut que quand il faut continuer et
donc parlé depuis 2004 aegis trust a
interviewé près de 300 victimes mais 28
ans après les faits nombreux d'entre eux
vieillissent être révélé les personnes
âgées parce que c'est si on les laisse
mourir sans donner leurs témoignages se
ce toute l'histoire qui est qui qui s'en
va l'urgence concerne aussi les archives
produite par l'association de rescapés
ibuka qui a accompagné les survivants
après 1994 ces milliers de documents
sont restés entassés au mémorial de
nyanza pendant des années depuis trois
mois l'historienne hélène dumas
travaille avec une équipe franco
rwandaise alors triage et leur
numérisation toutes les pertes sont
indiqués à la fois les pertes familial
mais aussi les pertes matérielles et
c'est encore une fois un témoignage de
ce qu'est un génocide quand il n'y a
plus rien cette histoire de la prise en
charge par les rescapés eux mêmes dans
deux problèmes qui sont des problèmes
considérables des problèmes matériels
des problèmes de justice des problèmes
de santé mentale c'est une valeur
historique majeur ce projet d'archivage
de la parole des victimes visent
également à empêcher la contestation de
ces faits historiques ça va nous aider à
lutter contre ces négationnistes parce
que
l'histoire la vraie histoire va
continuer à
être la différence si on augmente le
génocide des tutsi a fait entre ou huit
cent mille et un million de morts le
dernier recensement des rescapés à 2007
à l'époque il en restait environ 300
milles
et c'est la fin de journal de l'afrique
je vous retrouve dans moins d'une heure
pour une nouvelle édition a tout de
suite
[Musique]